Gregg you started your career working on
the documentary pins with Garth Davis so
when he calls do you give him first
priority okay of course the gas one of
my oldest friends so whenever Garth
calls I know that what he's gonna be
working on he's gonna be very
interesting and something that would
interest me so you know I've worked with
Garth probably longer than I've worked
with anybody else in the world and I've
known Garth probably longer than anybody
else other than my family so so I
understand the way he works I understand
his his methodology so you know he and I
are quite in tune when it comes to
things we like so chances are if he's
interested in something the chances are
I'll probably like it growing up how
obsessed were you with photography
cinematography I started my career as a
photographer so I studied photography at
in Melbourne for four three or four
years and then became a photographer I
was never really a true professional
photographer I was definitely making
money from it but I was never a you know
I'd it never reached the point where I
was kind of doing it full-time
professionally because I never actually
got a feel for it that was the problem
photographers generally tend to work the
business of photography generally is
quite until I and quite singular and so
I didn't really enjoy that aspect of it
I'm a more of a social being and I like
to actually work in groups and so that's
where filmmaking I think has the best of
both worlds you get the the best of
being a photographer could you make
pictures all day every day but then you
get the best of the group group work the
look of Lyon is incredible especially
the opening shots I mean it really
brings you into this like super natural
feel how are you setting the tone in the
beginning knowing that there's various
layers to the film parts of the story
the one thing that's beautiful about
Lyon it's it's a very spiritual film you
know the boy who becomes a man and his
essence is a spiritual being that that
it's constantly striving to get home and
one of the the points that garth raised
when we first started speaking about
this opening sequence was the story that
that's
who told Garth which was often when he
was a child he would astra travel well
what he thought was that he would as he
was going to bed he would leave his body
he would float across Australia float
across the sea and then go home his body
like this is how every every every night
he kind of imagined this would happen
and it wasn't until he discovered Google
Maps which became the physical you know
incarnation of what he was trying to do
that he actually then realized he was on
to something but but that opening
sequence was effectively his spirit
going home you know his starts in
Tasmania and it travels across Australia
it goes across an ocean lands in India
goes across India train tracks goes
across landscapes and then down into him
so it's him getting home so in some ways
you didn't believe it's you know it's
his spirit beginning the movie and it's
a really lovely way to start the movie
by by his spirit beginning the film yeah
it's absolutely beautiful the Train
scenes can you talk about some of the
technical aspects how you live the scene
well film in trends is very tricky
because classically you know that very
narrow carriages to walk in they don't
give you any more walk way than you need
as a passenger so to try and move up and
down them is very hard with a camera
it's very hard particularly when you're
slightly larger than your average Indian
moving trains are difficult because they
they definitely throw the camera around
a lot so keeping a steady image is quite
hard
we used a used to a gimbal for a lot of
the moving camera work in India so we
had an airy REM on the gimbal so we had
a great gimbal operator Brett from from
Melbourne come and join us in India and
he would basically just just run run
with the boy and the good thing about
that game was I could operate as well so
I could he could hold the camera in the
right spot or move it and then I could
with the wheels I could pan and tilt and
follow him so it was the closest thing
to having like a remote head
but on legs rather than a dully or
rather than a crane or or a Russian mmm
how many of the shots were handheld
versus uh I don't know the ratio
probably half I'd say but they were
definite times that we wanted to stop
the camera from being handheld so there
are different times where his story
slows so the camera needs to slow his
story of stops he takes rest he you know
he's taking taking in the world around
him so we need to make sure that the
cameras load at that at that point as
well so that was a often used stereo
camera long lens or or dolly so you
filmed in two countries I believe so
Tasmania which is what an island in
Australia is is the southernmost island
off the bottom of Australia
okay and then in India was it Calcutta
or but we also filmed in Ken watt which
is where he's from so you know the story
takes place in two cities in India and
two cities in Melbourne that's Kendra
and Calcutta and Hobart and Melbourne so
we filmed in India between Calcutta and
in Canberra and then we also filmed
between Hobart in Melbourne so each day
when you're reporting to set how early
is this that you're getting there and
what's that like
that's a good question it's a very done
depending on the day because obviously
there were some days that we needed to
go into night time and there were
certain limits that you can only work
with the with sunny of course because
he's like he's a young boy and you know
not to mention us old-timers having to
get to bed early and stuff like that so
we needed to with that change on a daily
basis depending on what we what we were
shooting so that first shot of the day
or night but but it's the first one that
you've set up how is that in terms of
the last shot do you think that there's
more fluidity toward the end and you
feel more comfortable or is it actually
are you sharper in the beginning no I
think you if it's the first part of a
sequence it's always slower because what
you're trying to do is trying to work
out what the sequence how the sequence
needs to take shape so if that happens
at the start of the day or happens at
the end of the day or towards the end of
the day
I think they're pretty pretty even
evenly paced it's pretty traditional
though for for the bulk of the work to
be done later because I think there's
just something kicks in when you're
filmmakers and you go well we're gonna
get four hours to go
we should really put the put the put on
the gas so I think your your level of
the amount that you achieve is a lot
higher in the afternoon okay
oh you know in the latter part the day
with the Google Earth shots were those
actual shots that you're filming from a
computer screen at times yep yep at
times we I think there was some I think
there was some computer-generated shots
at times but I think for the most part
we were trying to film off a computer
screen because it's just we wanted to
give it texture I wanted to make sure
there was texture reflections like we
wanted it not to be a flat kind of you
know like info doc oh that okay they
looked at this and then he looks at here
they looks here it wasn't about that
it's about the emotions so trying to
link that with him was really important
trying to see reflections trying to see
his face through reflections trying to
see the screen changed light on his face
in his eyes and his tears like it was
you know some beautiful moments where we
we had some great reflections in a tear
I remember watching it like a close-up
in his eyes the tear down I went I saw
the map I saw the map it is - yeah yeah
that was great - yeah seeing him with
the laptop and but how is that in terms
of the technical you know that the lens
picking up the screen because I know
maybe in the olden days you would
definitely see like this sort of hours
yeah I think that's because there are
different monitors CRT monitors that
refresh
I think LCDs or LED monitors don't
refresh anymore I think I'm not that
techie when it comes to that but I know
that traditionally laptop monitors I've
rarely had a problem with how was it in
India filming when it seemed like there
were people that were really from the
town these weren't actual extras and how
were they in terms of seeing this
machine this this thing that maybe they
don't see every day
or maybe they do well I don't know
people generally a very inquisitive in
India
it's a vast generalization some people
couldn't care that we were there but
some people were absolutely like
intrigued by this thing that we had
everybody knows that that the process of
filmmaking I mean you know it India
makes more films I think than any other
country in the planet I think they're
there they're the most prolific when it
comes to filmmaking so to believe that
people don't really know what's going on
it's kind of quite wrong because
everyone knows what's happening exactly
the process of filmmaking I think that's
were part of the entertainment they were
on the streets we were part of the
entertainment
you know if somebody was at the train
station there it may be at the train
station waiting for a train for hours
what else did they have to do like we
were part of the part of the sideshow so
trying to make sure that we weren't we
were giving everybody the entertainment
that they needed but weren't they
weren't getting in the way was part of
the challenge for us
Greg can we talk about the lighting kit
and how it varied from the Train versus
outdoors we one of the one of the the
challenging things on this movie which
is also one of the great things was that
we were quite limited in resources you
know we went to India we we didn't want
to carry around with us truck loads of
equipment because in the end it never it
wouldn't actually have helped us to have
you know hundreds of lights and the
ability to like that would have actually
slowed us down so what I tried to do is
we try to find locations that had a had
a base level of natural light that looks
really nice we did carry some H of mines
because we had a couple of scenes where
we had actually mice come through
windows but for the most part we used we
used LEDs we had one Pelican case with
three LED heads in it and we lit
predominantly most of India with three
small LED heads so we even the outdoor
scenes not just I mean the outdoor
scenes at night yes but the outdoor
scenes during the day I mean it's rare
my style of lighting would really bring
out lights for outdoors I mean there's
it'd be very rare for me to do that so
no I wouldn't pull LEDs out for the
the daytime I'd go with natural light
and then control the natural and going
back to when your beginnings was the
documentary pins one of your first
projects or do you eat did you do a lot
of short films I noticed that on your
credits you know that whole period is
have quite a blur because I remember
pins is a long long project it wasn't
just like a two-month project like pins
was I think we shot that over 15 months
or more and it wasn't full-time it was
sort of you know spits you know fits and
starts and you know a classic
documentary style it was like alright
there's an event going on alright cool
let's let's go and watch Warwick get
married you know we would go on film him
getting married in his wedding and it
would put three cameras on it and so
there were times yeah I was also
shooting short films and music videos
and and you know all sorts of other test
shoots and all sorts of things so that's
a good thing about cinematography I find
is that you know versus versus say
directing where when you direct
something you direct something for a
long period of time and you can't really
get your brain into something else
very easily whereas cinematography you
can flip between different styles and
documentary or a short film or you know
and like right now you know I've just
finished a film with Garth and I'm about
to do a commercial next week I mean
fantastic how much funds that I could do
a completely different style next week
than I did last week how is the
relationship with the subject whether
it's a documentary subject or an actor
and a narrative and the lens especially
in an intimate story like line but then
there's a lot of also wide shots but how
is that when you're trying to let's say
get a teardrop what is that like well as
a cinematographer or as a cameraman you
try to run the risk of you run the risk
of the camera impeding what's going on
now in a documentary definitely because
you don't ever want to stop something
from happening that should happen but
you also don't want to be the cause or
something to happen so good documentary
making is kind of writing that fine line
between but observing and not creating
but at the same time you know where the
line is is a is a blur sometimes
with filmmaking it's not dissimilar like
you know I was watching we were at Q&A
last night and I was actually with dev
in the green room and we're watching the
scene where he goes back and finds his
mom in India and I hadn't seen dev for
least yeah year and a half actually and
I was like dude remember that it was
like yesterday but it felt so long ago
it was like yesterday like I remember
exactly as he's walking I'm walking with
him I'm walking back with him oh I
couldn't see his mum that was a big
camera another camera but I couldn't see
him I wanted to get more into his eyes
but I don't wanna block his his view of
his mum so it's just writing the fine
line between being a passive observer
but also giving the audience what they
need which is seen into his eyes seeing
the scene seeing everything unfold so
trying to try to make trying to try to
play that role is is quite quite hard
but fun I mean it's fantastic you know I
just shot something with Garth and we
were in Italy and I don't know I
remember as a camera operator just just
being completely magnetized why these
actors like the camera couldn't not be
on them if it was on my shoulder or on
my hip it just just like it was like
literally it was a homing beacon just
like Paul following them everywhere they
went
I know you're too young to have really
worked with film but in terms of a lot
of film yeah or on film the digital okay
so so they know what to say so I can
talk for hours okay working with film
versus digital so many people feel that
in some sense digital so much easier to
use but do you really feel that and and
what is your preference I don't have a
preference I think that it's both are
tools that are extraordinary relevant I
think people some people have been
trying to put nail in the coffin of film
for a long time and some people have
been trying to put the nail in the well
when to the coffin of digital but people
have been trying to keep digital down I
don't think it is fair because both have
intrinsically their own their own
behavior and their own
value yeah I can't go into exactly the
value of each right now because it's all
very specific and very particular and if
I talk to a director then I'll tell them
my experience of a film and how it made
me feel well my experience at digital
there are certain times I shot digital
that I've been a bit underwhelmed at the
image quality or the
the quality of the inherent depth of the
of the image but also I've been shot on
film where I've been underwhelmed at the
at the quality coming back from the lab
has been scratched or you know like
there there's been issues with both so
it's about choosing the right format for
the right project at the right time and
so I don't have a strong opinion about
either it's about what's right for the
job and I love the fact that film still
exists right now I love it
it's because it's a done tool now I love
the fact that the Ariel X's existence I
love the fact that red is making a new
camera I love the fact that air is
making you I just love all these tools
it's like a kid in a candy store lastly
just wrapping up you got into
photography when you were younger who
was one of your idols like a Richard
Avedon or David Moore Australian
photographer
it was incredibly incredibly
inspirational bill Henson I think he's
an amazing bill Henson's a Australian
photographer as well who if you get an
opportunity to look up his work I mean
its controversial but it's stunning
beautiful value in the shadows and stuff
nan goldin then golden is incredible is
an amazing documentary photographer you
know one aspires to create images as
natural and as as kind of immediate as
chic as she can yeah Richard ever done
incredible does incredible logical
network I mean there's a lot of amazing
photographers out there and I think I
can can very safely say that I've taken
or been inspired by a lot of them in a
lot of instances that's good thing about
doing films too is that I can reference
Bill Henson for a film or I can
reference evident for a film but that
I'd have to be just an avid uninspired
film it could be the entire it could be
just a scene or a shot or
you know something something smaller